starting pitcher for the tigers is
michael former michael making his ninth
start of the season he's had 10 starts
in his career against the indians and
tonight he needs something positive and
a swing and a miss
one away in the cleveland first michael
threw a pretty good slider there the
ball broke down in the zone underneath
the swing of cesar hernandez
he swings here and pops it up
right to willy castro to the right of
second base makes the easy catch and
that's a really good first inning for
michael former after the way it started
great job
zach please sack will be the starting
pitcher for the tribe he was uh be
making his first start against the
tigers this year he made two against
them last year he's 1-0 in his career
and he got him candelario caught in
between didn't know what to do
and that's the first strikeout for
police
the next pitch swung on a weak ground
ball to the second baseman hernandez
throws out castro and plisac able to
work out of it so the indians and tigers
are scoreless after one
they can break a bat and hit it out
there
he went fishing
no bait
second strikeout for police
one down in hitting number two
he gets three strikes so he's swayed now
he doesn't back to back punches for
playsack two down in the second inning
strike three called got him looking at a
slider wow please sec came back and had
a nine pitch inning and he ends up
striking out the side immaculate inning
nine pitches three strikeouts
faces loaded knocking on the front door
there
stealing home
and he is out
alexander got romine the perfect throw
to get him at home plate
so one down and delino de shields will
step in
delino blasts one to center long run for
reyes he won't get it
and he can't cut it off and delilah will
go all the way to third
he's going to have a one-out triple and
that is huge for cleveland
now you get a chance to get him home
with only one out here in the fifth
inning
and that is in the air
and that should be good enough should be
deep enough
reyes makes the grab
his throat's coming home but it hits the
bound and delino scores easily the
indians lead it one to nothing give
lindor his 26th rbi on the year
joe jimenez he's in to work the sixth
for detroit against carlos santana
gets santana on a two-hopper to first
now reyes wedding in a 3-2 on the way
swinging to miss he just stayed with the
fan spawn got him good very smart what
he did just rear back it's got late life
to it and this is this is good steps for
joe brings up tyler naquin he swings and
pops it up
playable first base side candelario will
call off romaine lean back and make the
catch
over by that indians dugout good inning
for joey menez beautiful zach pleisek
has dominated detroit tonight with eight
strikeouts one walk and six innings of
shutout baseball
beautiful
low tracer nine strikeouts for police
one down here in the seventh
in the air to center field
two down
got him swinging
on another great change up 10 strikeouts
for playsack and zach playsack with
seven dominant shutout innings
back in his 19th game and again he's
been very consistent in the last couple
years for the tigers out of the pen
the one two
slam to left center
long run for derek hill boy did he make
up ground
wow can he cover that territory we've
talked about his range before he put it
on display right there
chased down an extra base hit from
friend neil reyes nice running grab to
keep it one nothing
it's been the zach police act show and
he's back out here for the eighth inning
sitting at 98 pitches
line drive caught by lindor
that's 12 in a row and 15 out of 16
retired by police
got him looking at a beautiful fastball
in the outside corner strikeout number
11. what an effort by zach pleisek
one-nothing indians lead the tigers in
the eighth
well the indians turned it over to one
of the top closers in the game brad hand
one nothing indians here in the ninth
rip to left center
cameron's second big one
chugging his way around second and he's
gonna head to third daz cameron comes up
huge here in the ninth
it's a one-out triple and gives detroit
a golden opportunity to tie
did he go the appeal he went too far and
bonifacio cannot believe it there are
two down
first base up by ryan blechney
brings him up here's the 2-2 from brad
hand
yes he did
got him that time and the ball game is
over
brad hand back-to-back strikeouts to
close out his 13th save of the year as
he works around a one-off triple here in
the bottom of the night and the indians
hang on for a hard-earned one-to-nothing
win
over the detroit tigers